This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二的保证。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立坚韧不拔的意志、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《百分之二》。就是数字的2。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方。在《回看过去》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是个重要的时刻。1984年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《回看过去》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you're not. you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast hello everybody welcome back to the show welcome back to the podcast new listeners old listeners
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《艰难成长记》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一层铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你不需要。你需要在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《艰难成长记》大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们
wherever you are in the world it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s i just want to say a huge big full thank you to all of the love and support that you guys have shown my new podcast, Matra, so far. In case you haven't heard, I launched a new show. You know, I just wanted to spend even more hours behind a microphone. One podcast wasn't enough. But Matra is basically a weekly podcast that I put out every single Monday that gives you a phrase and affirmation for your week to help you guide your week, whether it is I release the need for external validation, I cultivate peace within, I create my own reality, we go into what each mantra means at the start of every week to kind of give you
无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，当然，我们也会剖析20多岁时的心理状态。我只想对大家一直以来对我的新播客《曼特拉》所给予的爱与支持表示由衷的、巨大的感谢。如果你还没听说，我推出了一档新节目。你知道，我只是想在麦克风前花更多的时间。一个播客还不够。但《曼特拉》基本上是我每周一发布的一个每周播客，它为你提供一周的短语和肯定语，以帮助你度过这一周，无论是“我释放对外部认可的需求”、“我在内心培养平静”还是“我创造自己的现实”，我们都会在每周初深入探讨每个曼特拉的含义，以便为你提供
some guidance and some inspiration as you start things off and as you get into it, whatever it is you are going through. So the first episode was released yesterday on the 13th of January and the love that you guys have poured into that show already left me kind of speechless. So thank you so much for those who have already listened, already rated the show, who are following along on Instagram. Every single little two-second act, whether you're rating it, whether you're just playing the first, you know, 30 seconds, whether you honestly just hit follow means the world.
一些指导和灵感，当你们开始行动时，无论你们正在经历什么。所以第一集已经在1月13日昨天发布了，你们倾注到那个节目中的爱已经让我有点说不出话来。所以非常感谢那些已经收听、已经给节目评分、在Instagram上关注的人。每一个短短两秒钟的举动，无论是评分，还是只是播放前30秒，或者老实说只是点一下关注，都意义重大。
So I really, really appreciate it. But with that aside, just to say a big thank you, I want to talk about today's topic because today we are talking about alcohol, specifically what alcohol does to our brains, how it impacts us emotionally and psychologically, and also this shift we're kind of seeing in society today towards sobriety, especially in our generation of 20-somethings. A lot of us are starting to question whether our current drinking habits, both individually and as a culture, are really what's best. And this has been a big topic of conversation in my life at the moment.
所以我真的非常感谢。但抛开这些不说，为了表达由衷的感谢，我想聊聊今天的话题，因为今天我们正在谈论酒精，具体来说是酒精对我们大脑的影响，它如何在情感和心理上对我们产生影响，以及我们在当今社会看到的这种朝着戒酒转变的趋势，特别是在我们20多岁的这一代人当中。我们中的许多人开始质疑，我们目前饮酒的习惯，无论是个人还是作为一种文化，是否真的是最好的。这目前已经成为我生活中一个重大的谈话话题。
It's been coming up everywhere I look because I'm doing dry January. And you know what? I just kind of set it as a personal challenge. And if I'm being completely honest with you all, I did not expect it to be as hard as it was. It honestly shocked me a bit because I'm not someone who's ever had a problem with alcohol. I could always stop drinking what I wanted. But suddenly these 30 days have been hard.
无论我走到哪里，它都会出现，因为我正在进行“干燥一月”挑战（滴酒不沾的1月）。你知道吗？我只是把它当作一个个人挑战。如果我对大家坦诚相告，我并没有料到它会这么难。这老实说让我有点震惊，因为我并不是一个对酒精有问题的人。我总是能在我想停的时候停止喝酒。但突然间，这30天变得很艰难。
and it's really got me thinking about, well, the psychology of alcohol and the role that it plays during this decade of life. I think it's been so difficult because every social event or thing that's happening, every interaction or opportunity to hang out with my friends, kind of has alcohol at the centre, maybe not every single event, but probably every second one, whether it's going to the pub, going out for drinks, going to a party, a birthday, a celebration, dinner. Alcohol is very much at the centre. And honestly, is someone who actually does like the taste of wine and who will have a few glasses of wine or a beer, I never really noticed how dependent those situations felt on drinking until I put myself in a position where I couldn't participate in kind of the group activity.
这确实让我开始思考，嗯，酒精的心理学以及它在这个人生十年里扮演的角色。我认为之所以这么困难，是因为每一个社交活动或正在发生的事情，每一次互动或与朋友闲逛的机会，其核心似乎都有酒精，也许不是每个活动都是这样，但大概每两个活动里就有一次，无论是去酒吧，出去喝一杯，去参加派对、生日、庆祝活动、晚宴。酒精在其中占据了核心地位。老实说，作为一个确实喜欢葡萄酒的味道并且会喝几杯葡萄酒或啤酒的人，我从未真正注意到这些情况对饮酒的依赖程度有多高，直到我自己处于无法参与那种群体活动的境地。
What I have noticed has been really interesting as well, both. health-wise, mental health-wise, brain-wise, but also social-wise. So I want to not only discuss the role of alcohol on our brains and our bodies, because I think that's just something we should all understand, but also what happens when we quit alcohol, what changes you're likely to notice, how to deal with things like anxiety and the rise of sober curiosity amongst us. Also, some of the things I've learned going out sober that might surprise you. I also want to go kind of more in depth into the psychology of dependence, substance abuse, why we do feel like alcohol is so conditioned into how we socialize and so much more. I think this episode is really important and
我所注意到的也非常有趣，无论是健康方面、心理健康方面、大脑方面，还是社交方面。所以我不禁要讨论酒精对我们大脑和身体的作用，因为我认为这是我们所有人都应该了解的事情，而且还要讨论当我们戒酒时会发生什么，你可能会注意到哪些变化，如何应对焦虑等事情，以及我们当中对清醒状态好奇心的兴起。还有，我戒酒外出时学到的一些可能会让你惊讶的事情。我还想更深入地探讨依赖心理、药物滥用，为什么我们觉得酒精如此根深蒂固地融入到我们的社交方式中等等。我认为这一集非常重要，并且
it's essential listening if you're in your 20s and beyond because how often do we really pause and consider how big of a role this substance plays in our lives? You know, until recently, I hadn't really done that thinking. So this is also such a really richly and deeply researched area. I do just want to say the evidence and the science is constantly evolving when it comes to alcohol. Like a paper literally came out yesterday that I didn't get a chance to put into this episode. So as of right now, hopefully it is accurate. But maybe in a couple of years, the research will change again and I'll have to revisit this topic.
如果你正处于20多岁或更大的年龄，这是必听的内容，因为我们究竟有多经常真正停下来思考这种物质在我们的生活中扮演着多么重大的角色？你知道的，直到最近，我才真正进行过这种思考。所以这也是一个研究非常丰富和深入的领域。我只想说，说到酒精，证据和科学总是在不断发展的。就像昨天刚刚发表了一篇论文，我没有机会把它放进这一集里。所以就目前而言，希望它是准确的。但也许几年后，研究又会改变，我将不得不重新审视这个话题。
But for right now, this is what we know about the psychology. of alcohol, specifically in our 20s. So let's get into it. Let's get some basics down, Pat, first. How is alcohol processed by the body? Why does it make us feel the way it does? Good and bad. What is the impact on the brain? Three things we really need to know. So first thing to know, when you have a glass of wine, when you have a little apparel spritz, your martini, your shots of vodka, whatever it is, insert drink of choice here. The key chemical or substance that we are interested in that makes alcohol, alcohol is ethanol. This is what is going to make you feel tipsy or drunk and ethanol is really just a byproduct of the fermentation of a plant. So for wine,
但就目前而言，这就是我们所了解的关于酒精心理学的知识，特别是在我们20多岁的时候。让我们开始吧。首先把一些基础知识弄扎实。身体是如何代谢酒精的？为什么它让我们产生这种感觉？有好的也有坏的。对大脑有什么影响？我们需要真正了解的三件事。所以要知道的第一件事，当你喝了一杯葡萄酒，当你喝了一点开胃喷洒酒，你的马提尼，你的伏特加烈酒，无论是什么，在此处插入你选择的饮料。我们感兴趣的使酒精成为酒精的关键化学物质或物质是乙醇。这就是让你感到微醺或喝醉的原因，而乙醇其实只是植物发酵的副产品。所以对于葡萄酒来说，
it's grapes, for beer, it's barley, for vodka, it's, you know, potatoes or sugar or rice, gin, it's juniper berries. And fermentation basically just means that the fruit is rotting. It's fermenting. So when you drink alcohol, you're basically just drinking some really funky juice, you know, something that is rotten. And it's important to note that our body actually sees that in some ways as poison. Like it's not meant to be here, even if it feels nice. If you, for example, see someone throw up from drinking too much alcohol on a night out, that is basically your body being like, oh my gosh, we have been poisoned, get this stuff out of me. And I remember someone telling me that when I was at uni, actually. She was like,
是葡萄，对于啤酒来说是大麦，对于伏特加来说是马铃薯、糖或大米，对于金酒来说是杜松子。发酵基本上只意味着水果正在腐烂。它在发酵。所以当你饮酒时，你基本上只是在喝一些非常时髦的果汁，你知道的，已经腐烂的东西。值得注意的是，我们的身体在某些方面实际上将这视为毒药。就像它本来不应该在这里一样，即使感觉很好。如果你例如看到有人因为在夜生活里喝了太多酒而呕吐，那基本上就是你的身体在说，哦天哪，我们中毒了，把这东西从我体内弄出去。我记得我在大学时有人这么对我说过。她说，
like that is your body responding to a poison overdose and it really changed my whole perspective on how much I would drink on a night out like binge drinking was just so casually prevalent in my university experience that hearing that person explained it that way like kind of really shocked me so you know on a less extreme note when our body metabolizes alcohol ethanol even in small quantities a number of things happen. I'm not going to get too scientific, but essentially it can only be processed by our liver, which essentially does see ethanol
就像那是你的身体对药物过量作出的反应一样，这真的改变了我对自己在夜间外出时会喝多少酒的整个看法——酗酒在我的大学经历中是如此随意地普遍，以至于听到那个人用这种方式解释它，真的让我感到很震惊。所以，在一个没那么极端的层面上，当我们的身体代谢酒精乙醇时，即使是少量的，也会发生许多事情。我不会讲得太科学，但本质上它只能由我们的肝脏处理，肝脏基本上确实将乙醇视为
or something that is harmful, and it tries to clear it out of our system. It tries to clear it out of our body by processing it. But when we have more than the liver can process at any given time, this excess alcohol in our body is what starts to give us that loose, drunken, tipsy feeling, because the alcohol is not being processed as fast as it's coming in. That's not necessarily a problem at low levels, only at high levels.
有害的东西，它试图通过将其处理掉来将之清除出我们的系统。它试图通过处理来将之从我们的身体中清除。但是，当我们的体内的酒精超过了肝脏在任何给定时间所能处理的量时，我们体内这种过量的酒精就开始给我们那种松弛、喝醉、微醺的感觉，因为酒精被处理的速度赶不上它进来的速度。在低水平时这不一定是问题，只有在高水平时才是。
And all those feelings that we are going to be experiencing occur because alcohol is not only a drug, but it's what we call a depressant drug. So in comparison to stimulant drugs like MDMA, cocaine, that sort of thing, we have depressant drugs like alcohol, marijuana. Now, they're called depressants because of the impact they have on the central nervous system and the impact that alcohol or ethanol has is one of basically sedation. So your central nervous system, you hear that come up a lot. It is made up of two things,
我们即将体验到的所有这些感觉之所以会出现，是因为酒精不仅是一种药物，而且是我们所谓的镇静剂类药物。因此，与MDMA、可卡因等兴奋剂类药物相比，我们有酒精和大麻等镇静剂类药物。现在，它们被称为镇静剂是因为它们对中枢神经系统产生的影响，而酒精或乙醇产生的影响基本上是镇静作用的一种。所以你的中枢神经系统，你经常听到这个词。它由两部分组成，
your brain and your spine, your spinal cord. And alcohol is actually one of the few substances that can cross the blood brain barrier, meaning that it can almost reach into our brain cells and impact them directly. And when it does this, that it slows everything down and it disrupts normal functioning. So basically, at any given moment, right now, you right now listening to this podcast, all of your neurons in your brain are chattering away. They're sending information back and forth like little workers in a big warehouse and they're thinking, oh, this is interesting, this isn't interesting, pay attention to this
你的大脑和你的脊椎，你的脊髓。而酒精实际上是少数几种能够穿过血脑屏障的物质之一，这意味着它几乎可以伸入我们的脑细胞并直接对它们产生影响。当它这样做时，它会使一切慢下来并扰乱正常功能。因此，基本上在任何给定的时刻，就在现在，此时此刻正在听这个播客的你，你大脑中的所有神经元都在喋喋不休。它们像大仓库里的小工人一样来回发送信息，它们在想，哦，这很有趣，这不有趣，注意这个
while you're watching the road, while you're cleaning. They're sourcing all this information and alcohol is like going into that warehouse and slowly turning down the lights so that none of those little worker neurons can see where they're going and they can't talk as easily. That is basically alcohol's effect. It is kind of shutting down the systems, making it harder for your neurons to talk. Now this, this depress an effect on our brain is what creates so many of those typical effects that we associate with drinking. So, big one, feeling a little bit clumsy, a bit slower, but also less inhibiting. because all of those parts of your brain that would normally tell you to hush or would respond to
当你看着路时，当你打扫卫生时。它们在搜集所有这些信息，而酒精就像是走进那个仓库并慢慢调暗灯光，这样那些小神经元工人就看不清它们要去哪里，而且它们不能那么容易地交流。这基本上就是酒精的作用。它有点像关闭系统，使你的神经元更难交流。现在，这种对我们大脑的镇静作用创造了许多我们与饮酒相关联的典型效果。所以，一个很大的影响是，感觉有点笨拙、慢半拍，但也减少了抑制。
physical stimuli, they are kind of quietening down, they're finding it harder to communicate with each other. Think about like in a normal circumstance, you go to say something embarrassing or weird and your brain goes, okay, let's read the cues, let's think this through. We're not going to say that. But when you're drinking, your brain gets to that realization a little bit too slow. It also slows down our anxiety, meaning that your anxious thoughts for a lot of us finally seem quieter. We're going to talk about that in a second and why that's actually going to backfire on you.
因为你大脑中所有那些通常会告诉你安静下来或对身体刺激做出反应的部分，它们正在平静下来，它们发现彼此沟通变得更困难。想想看，在正常情况下，你去说一些尴尬或奇怪的话，你的大脑就会说，好吧，让我们解读一下线索，让我们仔细想想。我们不会说那个。但是当你喝酒时，你的大脑得出这个认识的速度会慢一点。它还减缓了我们的焦虑，这意味着对我们许多人来说，你的焦虑情绪终于看起来更安静了。我们一会儿就会讨论这一点，以及为什么这实际上会对你产生反作用。
Another impact that alcohol has that comes from that sedative effect is slurred speech. It's why you should also never drive when drinking because your response times are slower, even if you don't think that they are. It's why we feel sleepy. Alcohol also causes our brain to release something called opioid peptides, which basically are the thing that signals the brain to release dopamine and serotonin. And when they do, those areas of our brain open the floodgates and they let out, they make more of these neurotransmitters available to us, which is what makes us feel really happy and euphoric
酒精产生的另一个来自该镇静效果的影响是口齿不清。这也是为什么你绝对不能在喝酒后开车，因为你的反应时间变慢了，即使你认为自己没有变慢。这就是为什么我们会感到困倦。酒精还会导致我们的大脑释放一种叫做阿片肽的东西，这基本上是向大脑发出信号以释放多巴胺和血清素的东西。当它们这样做时，我们大脑的那些区域打开了闸门，它们释放出来，使更多的这些神经递质对我们可用，这正是让我们感到非常快乐和欣快的原因
because of how this substance impacts our reward pathways and also the release of endorphins. So alcohol triggers opioid peptides, which trigger dopamine and serotonin, and in the process also releases endorphins. It's interesting because they actually only really discovered that this is what was happening, this peptide to dopamine to endorphin link. About 12 years ago, you know, they long, assumed it, but it was really hard to prove that this was why alcohol made us so happy. The way they did finally prove it was that they did a study back in 2012 where they injected
因为这种物质如何影响我们的奖赏通路以及内啡肽的释放。有趣的是，他们实际上直到最近才真正发现这就是正在发生的事情，这种肽到多巴胺再到内啡肽的联系。大约12年前，你知道的，他们长期以来一直这么假设，但很难证明这就是为什么酒精让我们如此快乐的原因。他们最终证明这一点的方法是，他们在2012年做了一项研究，当时他们注射了
25 people, half of whom were heavy drinkers, half of whom weren't, with a drug that would bind their opioid receptors. But then they radioactively tagged those receptors. So they basically gave them a low level of a drug that stimulated their opioid receptors and that drug would obviously attached to those receptors so they could see where they were in the brain. And then they asked them to drink alcohol. And the people who got particularly a lot of pleasure out of drinking, so heavy drinkers, they, all those areas, those places where the opioid peptides were located based on that previous drug insertion, they lit up even further. And so that really showed researchers and scientists, only 12 years ago, that that was the system and the reason why we get that euphoric
25个人，其中一半是重度饮酒者，一半不是，使用了一种能与其阿片受体结合的药物。但随后他们对这些受体进行了放射性标记。所以他们基本上给他们低剂量的药物，刺激他们的阿片受体，而该药物显然会附着在这些受体上，这样他们就可以看到它们在大脑中的位置。然后他们要求他们喝酒。那些从饮酒中获得特别多快乐的人，也就是重度饮酒者，他们根据之前注射药物确定位点所在的阿片肽所在的所有区域，甚至进一步亮了起来。因此，这向研究人员和科学家们真正展示了，仅仅在12年前，这就是我们获得那种欣快感的系统和原因。
feeling. So the effects of alcohol, they're not just physical and biological. They're also really psychological, not just because of that happy feeling, but because of the impact on our mind and our mood in general and also our personality. This amazing paper from 2008 titled, Why Do We Drink? Puts it really perfectly. We drink because of alcohol's ability to alter our emotional state. and make us more like the person we actually want to be, even if just for a second. We want to be the confident person, the relaxed person, the disinhibited person, the less stress person. And because alcohol gives us a gateway to this realization of the ideal self, that is actually
因此，酒精的影响不仅仅是身体和生物学上的。它们也确实是心理上的，不仅因为那种快乐的感觉，还因为对我们的思维、总体情绪以及我们的性格产生的影响。这篇2008年题为《我们为什么喝酒？》的精彩论文完美地阐述了这一点。我们喝酒是因为酒精能够改变我们的情绪状态，并让我们更像我们真正想要成为的人，哪怕只是短短一秒钟。我们想成为自信的人、放松的人、不受束缚的人、压力较小的人。由于酒精为实现这个理想自我提供了一条途径，这实际上是
what can make it so addictive and what can fuel dependency. You know, it's not just the feeling. it's who it makes us become in comparison to who we are in our everyday lives. You know, that is one factor. I also think the other factor why the other reason it's so normalized and widely used is, of course, the social element to it. How can we forget that? You know, that social celebratory component to the use of alcohol is what makes it so hard for us
使其如此容易上瘾并助长依赖性的原因。你知道，这不仅仅是那种感觉；与我们在日常生活中的身份相比，它是关于它让我们变成谁。你知道，这是一个因素。我也认为另一个因素，即它如此标准化和广泛使用的另一个原因，当然是其中的社交元素。我们怎么能忘记这一点呢？你知道，酒精使用的这种社交庆祝成分使我们很难考虑远离它，因为我们认为我们会错过许多其他的事情，
to contemplate stepping away from it because we think that we're going to miss out on so many other things. you know, for millennium, people have known that alcohol makes us have more fun. It makes us merry, makes us open, more relaxed. And so it has become integrated into our culture, our way of communicating and socializing. You know, the earliest evidence of humans making and drinking alcohol was from 7,000 BC before Christ. That is a lot of years ago. That is definitely not modern history. Actually, where they found this wine was in China, in what is now known as the Yellow River Valley. And it really goes to show that humans have for a long time used this substance to alter their state of mind and for enjoyment. Now, you can obviously get this
你知道，几千年来，人们一直都知道酒精能让我们获得更多乐趣。它让我们快乐、开朗、更放松。因此，它已融入我们的文化、我们的沟通和社交方式中。你知道，人类制造和饮酒的最早证据可以追溯到公元前7000年。那是很多年前的事了。这绝对不是现代历史。实际上，他们发现这种酒是在中国，即现在被称为黄河流域的地方。这确实表明，人类长期以来一直使用这种物质来改变他们的精神状态以获取快乐。现在，你显然可以通过仅仅一杯酒甚至几杯酒获得这种
buzzed, euphoric, relax feeling from even just one drink, even a couple of drinks. But at some point, your body can't process the alcohol fast enough. And so initially you will get that buzzed feeling and then you'll start feeling nauseous, dizzy, confused. And you may even black out. Let's actually talk about what happens to your brain when you black out. Now, I'm talking blacking out, not passing out. So not like, you know, being completely unconscious, but being conscious but having no
微醺、欣快、放松的感觉。但在某个时候，你的身体无法足够快地代谢酒精。因此，最初你会得到那种微醺的感觉，然后你开始感到恶心、头晕、神志不清。你甚至可能会断片。让我们实际谈谈当你断片时你的大脑会发生什么。现在，我说的是断片，而不是昏迷。所以不是像，你知道的，完全失去意识，而是保持清醒但没有
memory of what has happened. When this happens, you've basically drunk enough. alcohol to disrupt a really vital part of your brain called the hippocampus. Now, this part of your brain, it's responsible for a lot of things. But in this context, it's really responsible for consolidating and storing memories. So although you might be awake and you might be currently experiencing your reality, your brain cannot take those moments and store them properly. So that is what leads to those gaps in what you can remember.
发生的事情的记忆。当这种情况发生时，你基本上已经喝了足够多的酒精，以至于扰乱了你大脑中一个至关重要的部分，也就是海马体。现在，这部分大脑负责很多事情。但在这种情况下，它主要负责巩固和储存记忆。所以，尽管你可能醒着，也可能正在经历你的现实，但你的大脑无法将那些时刻记录并妥善存储起来。这就是导致你记忆中出现那些空白的原因。
Everything that you're experiencing when you're really drunk on a night out or wherever you are, basically it's only able to be temporarily held in sensory and short-term memory, which normally has a life expectancy of about a couple of minutes. So that's why you might wake up the next morning and go, hey, this is so blurry. I can't remember saying that. I can't remember doing that, even though you haven't necessarily passed out at any point. When we pass out, on the other hand, what we are experiencing is, as I described before,
当你外出狂欢或身处任何地方喝得酩酊大醉时，你所经历的一切，基本上只能暂时保存在感觉记忆和短期记忆中，而这些记忆的存活时间通常只有大约两分钟左右。所以这就是为什么你第二天醒来时可能会想，天哪，这也太模糊了。我不记得自己说过那些话了，我不记得自己做过那些事了，尽管你可能在任何时候都没有真正不省人事。另一方面，当我们失去意识时，我们所经历的正如我之前所描述的，
basically minor alcohol poisoning. And when I say minor, I mean less extreme than the worst case scenario, but honestly, any kind of alcohol poisoning is not that great. And the next morning, you know, how can we talk about the psychology of alcohol and not talk about the next day? When we've drunk past that limit, we get a hangover. and that's typically due to dehydration and because when your liver breaks down alcohol, a byproduct is called ancetalahide, which is what makes you really nauseous and gives you headaches.
基本上是轻度酒精中毒。当我说是轻度时，我的意思是它不如最糟糕的情况那么极端，但老实说，任何形式的酒精中毒都不是什么好事。到了第二天，你知道的，我们怎么能只谈论酒精的心理学而不谈论第二天呢？当我们饮酒超过那个限度时，我们就会宿醉，这通常是由于脱水造成的，而且当你的肝脏分解酒精时，会产生一种叫做乙醛的副产物，这正是让你感到极度恶心并头痛欲裂的原因。
And then we also have anxiety as a component of that. I made a full episode on anxiety maybe two years ago. The episode is called the Psychology of Anxiety that goes really into depth on this subject. but as a summary, when we drink, part of why we feel that calm feeling I was talking about is also because of the release of a neurotransmitter called Gaba. And in response to alcohol, our brain dumps a bunch of this into our body. Gabba has that sedative effect. It really slows things down.
然后，我们也有焦虑作为其中的一个组成部分。我大约在两年前做过一期关于焦虑的完整节目。那期节目叫做《焦虑心理学》，对这个主题进行了深入探讨。但简单总结一下，当我们喝酒时，我们感到平静的那部分原因，也是因为一种叫做GABA（γ-氨基丁酸）的神经递质的释放。为了应对酒精，我们的大脑将大量这种物质倾倒到体内。GABA具有镇静作用。它确实能让事情慢下来。
It reduces your anxiety. It reduces chatter between your neurons. The next day, though, our brain is like, all right, cool. We need to get everything back in balance now. So it releases more of Gabba's counterpart, glutamate. Now, glutamate has the opposite effect. It has an excitatory effect. And that is why you feel quite anxious the next morning
它能减少你的焦虑。它能减少神经元之间的喋喋不休。不过到了第二天，我们的大脑就像是在说，好吧，酷。我们现在需要让一切恢复平衡了。于是，它释放了更多GABA的对应物——谷氨酸。现在，谷氨酸具有相反的效果。它具有兴奋作用。这就是为什么第二天早晨你会感到相当焦虑
because it takes a while for your brain to really find the right level and restore that normal chemical balance. So it's pumping in more glutamate, pumping in more gabba, pumping in more glutamate. And, you know, they're kind of trying to race to the top and your anxiety is rising and rising. That is why you can feel really overwhelmed by, oh my God, what did I say last night? What did I do? Even when you didn't do anything, you feel like there's this lingering sense that something is wrong and this rising anxiety in your body. That, my friends, is glutamate. So I think, you know, that even that interaction between Gabba and glutamate really sums up
因为你的大脑需要一段时间来真正找到合适的水平并恢复正常的化学平衡。所以它在注入更多的谷氨酸，注入更多的GABA，注入更多的谷氨酸。而且，你知道的，它们有点像在争先恐后地冲向顶峰，你的焦虑感也在不断上升。这就是为什么你会对以下事情感到无比不知所措，比如，天哪，我昨晚都说了些什么？我都做了什么？即使你什么也没做，你也会觉得有一种挥之不去的异样感，身体里的焦虑感也在不断上升。我的朋友们，这就是谷氨酸。所以我觉得，你知道的，GABA和谷氨酸之间的这种相互作用真正总结了
alcohol consumption for me. For every reaction you have with alcohol, there is a counter reaction. you might feel happy and merry, but then the next day you might feel sad and depressed. When the buzz wears off, you might feel uninhibited, but the next day you feel anxious again. And for me, alcohol also was just a really terrible contributor to my mental health, because obviously, like you're feeling stressed and overwhelmed. You've had a really hard day. You might have a couple glasses of wine, but I was finding that I would wake up the next day. Firstly, I wasn't as productive.
对我而言的酒精消费。你对酒精的每一次反应，都有一个相反的反应。你可能会感到快乐和愉快，但第二天你可能会感到悲伤和沮丧。当兴奋感消退后，你可能会感到无拘无束，但第二天你又会感到焦虑。对我来说，酒精也是对我心理健康的一个非常糟糕的推手，因为显然，你感觉压力山大、不知所措。你度过了非常艰难的一天。你可能会喝上几杯葡萄酒，但我发现我第二天醒来时。首先，我的效率没有那么高了。
I didn't have as much mental clarity. which is so important to me. But secondly, all of my anxious, stressful, worrisome feelings and sensations were just heightened and elevated and it was unbearable. And that is something that I have noticed, you know, in this short period of time, and there's two weeks that I haven't been drinking. My anxiety symptoms have declined. Like they're still there, but they feel manageable.
我没有那么清晰的思维，这对我来说太重要了。但其次，我所有的焦虑、压力、担忧的感觉和感受都被放大和拔高了，简直令人无法忍受。这也是我注意到的事情，你知道的，在这段短短的时间里，也就是我没有喝酒的两周里。我的焦虑症状有所减轻。它们虽然还在，但感觉是可以控制的。
Also, I'm getting, you know, riding less of. of a wave, like an up and down wave of spiked emotions from really jubilant to really, you know, terrified and sad. Very interested to see how that goes like in the next two weeks after a month. And even if I can do like six months, I don't know. I've got, you know, my book coming out. I kind of want to have a little glass of champagne with that. But even in moderation, whether my alcohol consumption is something that is directly correlated to poor mental health episodes for me. I do want to put in like a little disclaimer here. Like this advice and information I'm presenting isn't presented in a way to just be like, everyone be sober and trying to
另外，你知道的，我的情绪波动变小了，不再像坐过山车那样经历从极度狂喜到极度恐惧和悲伤的情绪大起大落。非常好奇接下来两周到一个月内情况会怎样。甚至如果我能坚持六个月的话，我也不知道。你知道的，我的书就要出版了。我挺想用它来喝一小杯香槟的。但即使是适度饮酒，我的酒精摄入是否直接与我心理健康状况不佳的阶段相关。我想在这里加一个小小的免责声明。就像我提出的这些建议和信息并不是为了表现得好像是在说，大家都戒酒并试图
dissuade you from ever drinking again. Like I think I will eventually drink again. I just also think that what I needed to understand was some of the consequences and, you know, really re-acknowledging myself what was happening in my body in response to alcohol and whether I was willing to opt into that interaction or whether I'd be better off without it. But I honestly do think, like, I'll drink again. I probably will get drunk again, probably a couple of times. So this isn't like a blanket. If you're listening to this, never drink again kind of episode. I just think that any form of education gives you an informed choice. And you can take this and be like, cool, I'm still going to get blackout drunk. And I wouldn't, you know, I wouldn't promote that. But it's still your choice,
劝阻你再也不要喝酒一样。我觉得我最终还是会喝酒的。我也只是觉得，我需要了解一些后果，并且，你知道的，重新向自己确认酒精对我的身体产生了什么反应，以及我是否愿意参与这种互动，或者没有它我会过得更好。但老实说，我觉得，我会再次喝酒的。我可能还会喝醉，大概会有好几次。所以这并不是一概而论的那种——如果你在听这个，就再也不要喝酒了——的节目。我只是认为任何形式的教育都能让你做出明智的选择。你可以接受这个然后觉得，酷，我还是要喝到断片。虽然我不会，你知道的，我不会提倡这种做法。但这仍然是你的选择，
as long as you know what you're doing to your body. All right, let's take a short break because something we haven't spoken about yet is the psychology behind alcohol dependency and addiction. I think that deserves its whole section of the podcast. So we will be back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs
只要你知道你对自己的身体做了什么。好了，让我们稍事休息，因为我们还没有谈到的一点是酒精依赖和成瘾背后的心理学。我认为这值得成为播客的一个完整板块。所以我们在这个短暂的休息后就会回来。2%。这就是走楼梯的人所占的比例，
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
同时也有自动扶梯可用。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hard. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难的事情，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字 TWO%。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗丝在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈 80 年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说更重要了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会
get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
如此全神贯注于追逐，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于胜利与失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines,
因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
在我的新播客《The Hard Way》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的 IHeart Radio 应用程序，搜索《The Hard Way》，立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency, in her story. This began a year's long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的不一致之处。这就开始了长达数年的法律诉讼来证明真相。你在某个测试上造假了两次，对吗？我造假了一次测试。这需要
an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Why is it that some people cannot stop drinking when they start? Why do some people get really drunk, make terrible mistakes, ruin relationships, and they still cannot quit? Basically, I think the question that I'm asking is, what makes alcohol so addictive for some people? And it really, it really is, even if we don't acknowledge it. Researchers at Oxford University, they've actually called it the second most addictive drug on
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。为什么有些人一旦开始喝酒就停不下来？为什么有些人喝得酩酊大醉，犯下可怕的错误，毁掉人际关系，却依然戒不掉？基本上，我认为我提出的问题是，是什么让酒精对某些人如此容易上瘾？而且它确实如此，即使我们不承认这一点。牛津大学的研究人员实际上称它是
the planet second only to heroin. Like, that's why. to me. Yet it's so widely accepted. If, you know, we were all going around doing heroin every Friday, Saturday, and odd Tuesday, you best believe that your friends would be like, hey, intervention happening here, this isn't a good idea. But alcohol is just not treated with the same level of caution. What really makes alcohol so addictive, and I've already kind of mentioned it, is what it does to us psychologically as well as physically. And psychologically, what it does is that it numbs us, but not only that, it also lights up the reward centres in our brain. So, you know, of course our brain is going to continue to repeat behaviors or tell us to
地球上仅次于海洛因的第二大最容易上瘾的药物。所以，这就是为什么。对我来说。然而它却被如此广泛地接受。如果，你知道的，我们所有人都每周五、周六和偶尔周二去注射海洛因，你最好相信你的朋友会说，嘿，这里正在进行干预，这不是个好主意。但对于酒精，人们却没有给予同等水平的谨慎对待。到底是什么让酒精如此让人上瘾，我已经提到过一点了，那就是它在心理和生理上对我们产生的影响。在心理上，它的作用是让我们麻木，不仅如此，它还会点燃我们大脑中的奖赏中心。所以，你知道的，我们的大脑当然会继续重复这些行为，或者告诉我们去
repeat behaviors that are pleasurable, rewarding. And also, you know, alcohol provides relief in a sense from really hard things, from negative circumstances. When that association between, you know, alcohol makes me happy, alcohol takes away bad things. When that association becomes a pattern that becomes a habit, it becomes a lot harder and harder to stop. We also have to acknowledge, you know, a lot of people feel more like themselves, I guess, in their drunk state. And so, of course, they're going to continue to drink and sometimes drink heavily to put them back in the shoes of this person they wish that they were. This really, this pattern
重复那些带来快乐、有回报的行为。而且，你知道的，酒精在某种程度上提供了从极其艰难的事情、从负面环境中解脱出来的感觉。当这种联系变成一种模式，变成一种习惯时，即“酒精让我快乐，酒精能带走不好的事情”，要想停下来就会变得越来越难。我们还必须承认，你知道的，很多人在喝醉的状态下感觉更像他们自己，我猜是这样。所以，当然，他们会继续喝酒，有时会大量饮酒，让自己回到他们希望成为的那个人的状态。这种模式
and association is really the neurological basis for addiction. And we typically see addiction as happening in three stages. So if we're speaking of alcohol, often people begin with the binge and intoxication stage where we're experiencing all the pleasure, we're experiencing all the happy thoughts. We associate drinking with really fun things, environments, people, and it hasn't gotten bad yet. But then we get to the withdrawal period where it just feels quills. crap to not be drinking because of the hangovers, whatever, and also the negative effect stage. So when we do stop, we become irritable, sad, depressed, anxious, anxious.
和联系确实是成瘾的神经学基础。我们通常认为成瘾分为三个阶段。所以如果我们谈论酒精，人们通常从暴饮和中毒阶段开始，在这个阶段我们体验到所有的快乐，体验到所有的快乐想法。我们将饮酒与非常有趣的事情、环境、人联系起来，而且事情还没有变得糟糕。但随后我们进入了戒断期，因为宿醉等原因，不喝酒感觉糟透了，还有消极情绪阶段。所以当我们真正停下来时，我们会变得易怒、悲伤、抑郁、焦虑、焦虑。
So we drink again to reduce the stress of not drinking. And then that is really followed by the preoccupation and anticipation stage. This is when we have strong urges. We have cravings when they're not acceptable. Maybe we are watching the clock for 5pm. We're sneaking drinks at work. this is where we don't feel like we can have fun without it. We don't think we can function without it.
所以我们再次喝酒来减轻不喝酒带来的压力。随之而来的真的是全神贯注和期待阶段。这是我们产生强烈冲动的时候。当不适合喝酒时，我们会有这种渴望。也许我们在盯着时钟等下午5点。我们在工作时偷喝酒。这就是我们感觉没有它就无法获得快乐的地方。我们认为没有它我们就无法运转。
And it's where, you know, alcohol abuse disorder and alcohol addiction really kind of takes hold. Some of us are more prone to this than others. And one of the biggest factors that makes us more prone to it is genetics. It's genetic factors. And recent studies, including one from only last year, have showed that there are certain genes associated with an addiction. or dependency on alcohol, and those genes are inherited. Some, you know, scientists, some researchers even call substance use disorders or alcoholism a complex genetic disease, a genetic disease like, you know, those that cause birth defects
而这也是酒精滥用障碍和酒精成瘾真正开始起作用的地方。我们中的一些人比其他人更容易受到这种影响。而导致我们更容易受到影响的最大因素之一就是遗传。它是遗传因素。最近的研究，包括去年的研究，表明某些基因与对酒精的成瘾或依赖有关，而且这些基因是遗传的。一些科学家甚至研究人员称物质使用障碍或酗酒为复杂的遗传疾病，一种像导致先天缺陷
or birth deformities. And it's also linked to generational trauma. It's linked to environment, to learn behaviors, all of which are kind of passed down from those above us, passed down from our family. And, you know, of course, trauma comes into play here. You know, a study in Australia found that a third of adults who were exposed to childhood trauma go on to abuse alcohol later in life. A third of them. And, you know, as a country who has Australia being, you know,
或先天畸形的遗传疾病。它还与代际创伤有关。它与环境、习得的行为有关，所有这些都是由我们上面的人传承下来的，由我们的家庭传承下来的。而且，当然，创伤在这里发挥了作用。澳大利亚的一项研究发现，三分之一遭受过童年创伤的成年人在晚年生活中会滥用酒精。三分之一的人。而且，作为一个拥有澳大利亚这样
as a terrible history, a terrible, terrible history, you know, you can see why, people whose families and whose culture have endured that suffering would have problems with alcohol because as it's as it's called it's a complex genetic and generational disease that's how some people really see it this is why um i really think that people who struggle with alcoholism or substance addiction or abuse of any kind they deserve so much sympathy um maybe people get upset at me for saying that and say, you know, no, my uncle has this and he doesn't deserve a lick of sympathy. He did this to himself. That's your perspective and your truth.
有着糟糕历史，糟糕透顶历史的国家，你可以理解为什么那些家庭和文化经历过这种痛苦的人会对酒精有问题，因为正如它所被称为的那样，这是一种复杂的遗传和代际疾病，这就是一些人真正的看法。这就是为什么嗯，我真的认为那些与酗酒、物质成瘾或任何形式的滥用作斗争的人，他们值得那么多的同情。也许人们会因为我这么说而感到不安，并说，不，我叔叔有这个毛病，他一点同情都不配。这是他自找的。那是你的视角和你的真相。
What I'm saying is that I don't think anyone would choose that life for themselves. No one, as a child, as a three, four, five year old says, when I grow up, I want to be dependent on alcohol. No one dreams of that. But I've also seen in my own life how easy it is to fall into that pattern. and I've seen this in people that I know who seem totally fine and normal, but have serious problems with alcohol. They're just able to hide it because they have a good support network
我想说的是，我认为没有人会为自己选择那种生活。没有人，作为一个三、四、五岁的孩子，会说当我长大后，我想依赖酒精。没有人会梦想那样。但我也在自己的生活中看到陷入这种模式是多么容易，我在我认识的那些看起来完全正常和优秀的人身上看到了这一点，但他们对酒精有严重的问题。他们只是能够隐藏它，因为他们有一个良好的支持网络
because of, you know, other things in their life. You know, I just don't think that it really comes down to not being disciplined. I think that or being lazy. I really actually think that it can happen to anyone. All it takes is one tragedy. bad year, one instance of bad luck. And all you have left might be alcohol. That is how you self-sooth.
因为生活中的其他事情。我知道，我只是认为这真的不仅仅是缺乏纪律。我认为或者是因为懒惰。我其实真的认为这可能发生在任何人身上。所需要的只是一场悲剧，糟糕的一年，一次倒霉的经历。而你剩下的可能只有酒精。这就是你自我安慰的方式。
And I think it's as simple as that. It's such a widely available and accepted drug that there's also people who don't even question that they might have a problem until it's too late. You know, living in Australia, we have such a huge binge drinking culture that I'm so sure that there are people I would even know who don't even realize. that they have a problem until they would try to stop until they'd try to quit. And, you know, they couldn't do it. Like, even I struggled.
我认为事情就是这么简单。它是一种如此广泛可用且被接受的药物，以至于也有人甚至不会质疑自己是否有问题，直到为时已晚。你知道，生活在澳大利亚，我们有如此巨大的酗酒文化，以至于我非常确信，我甚至认识那些甚至没有意识到自己有问题的人，直到他们试图戒酒，直到他们试图戒掉。而且，你知道，他们做不到。就像，甚至我也曾苦苦挣扎。
There's also the important thing to remember, which is that alcohol is commonly used as a maladaptive coping mechanism because of, again, how it can be used to help us manage stress, bad thoughts, inadequacy. It does remove bad feelings, but it also prevents a deeper, truer, form of emotional coping. I think we really need to articulate the distinction here between dependence, abuse and addiction because they are used very interchangeably, even I've been doing so. So let's clarify this for a second. When people use the term dependence, they are usually referring to a physical dependence on a substance.
还有一点很重要，需要记住，那就是酒精通常被用作一种不良的应对机制，因为再次强调，它可以用来帮助我们管理压力、糟糕的想法、不安全感。它确实消除了不好的感觉，但它也阻止了一种更深层、更真实的形同情感应对的方式。我认为我们真的需要在依赖、滥用和成瘾之间明确区别，因为它们经常被交替使用，甚至我一直在这么做。所以让我们花一秒钟澄清这一点。当人们使用依赖这个词时，他们通常指的是对某种物质的身体依赖。
So what that is characterized by is symptoms of increased tolerance. So it's harder for you to get drunk even as you drink more and also withdrawal. So obviously withdrawal is the removal of the substance when you are sober. It doesn't feel great. You feel sick. You feel gross as the alcohol leaves your body. And while it's possible to have a physical dependence without being addicted, often, it's a very slippery slope and it's right around the corner.
因此，其特征是耐受性增加的症状。因此，即使你喝得更多，你也更难喝醉，还有戒断症状。所以很明显，戒断是在你清醒时移除这种物质。感觉不太好。当酒精离开你的身体时，你会觉得生病，觉得恶心。虽然在没有成瘾的情况下也有可能有身体依赖，但通常情况下，这是一条非常滑的坡路，而且它就在拐角处。
Addiction is one step above dependence because it's marked by a change in behavior that is caused not only by biochemical changes in the brain from using. alcohol, but also psychological changes, you know, linked to substance abuse. The substance, and in this case it's alcohol, becomes the main priority for someone who is suffering from addiction, regardless of the harm they cause to themselves or others. So this is a really important part, even if it's hurting family members, even if you're going to lose your job, like you just cannot stop. You just cannot stop.
成瘾比依赖高出一步，因为它的标志是行为的改变，这种改变不仅是由使用酒精在大脑中引起的生物化学变化引起的，还由与物质滥用有关的心理变化引起的。这种物质，在这种情况下是酒精，成为了患有成瘾症的人的首要任务，而不管它对他们自己或他人造成了什么伤害。所以这是一个非常重要的部分，即使它伤害了家庭成员，即使你会失去工作，就像你就是无法停止。你就是无法停止。
something interesting though is that you can be addicted to alcohol and not abusing it or even using it like you could be completely sober and still addicted to alcohol which sounds strange but it's actually a very core philosophy of alcoholics anonymous that you're basically always going to be an addict you know there was some controversy around this because if you tell someone who's zero days sober hey, no matter what you do, you're always going to be an addict and that is a bad, dirty word, so you better not, it's not even worth trying. Like, that's not a fun thing to hear. You know, it's not a fun thing to think that you're forever going to be under the control of this substance
不过有趣的是，你可能对酒精成瘾却没有滥用它，甚至没有使用它，就像你可以完全清醒却仍然对酒精成瘾一样，这听起来很奇怪，但实际上是匿名戒酒会（AA）的一个核心哲学，即你基本上永远都是一个瘾君子。你知道，这引发了一些争议，因为如果你告诉一个戒酒零天的人，嘿，不管你做什么，你永远都是一个瘾君子，这是一个糟糕的、肮脏的词，所以你最好不要，甚至不值得去尝试。这可不是什么好听的话。你知道，认为自己将永远在这个物质的控制之下的想法可不好受
or your identity is going to be associated with this substance. So some people have said that idea that you're always an addict is not necessarily good for an optimistic internal environment. But there are people who say, you know, knowing that you're always an addict, you know, you are someone who is always going to be an addict, who was an addict, serves as a good reminder to them that they do have a more addictive prone personality. So they shouldn't take chances, even trying to drink alcohol as in a normal way. Like that is not something that they can do.
或者你的身份将与这种物质联系在一起。所以有些人说，你永远是一个瘾君子的想法对积极的内部环境不一定好。但也有人说，你知道，知道自己永远是一个瘾君子，你知道，你是一个永远都是瘾君子的人，曾经是瘾君子，这很好地提醒了他们，他们确实有更容易成瘾的个性。所以他们不应该冒险，甚至像正常人一样尝试喝酒。这绝对不是他们能做到的事。
So wherever you sit on that kind of scale of whether you think it should exist that you're always an addict or not, like it's very much an individual choice, what's going to allow you to move past, dependency and addiction in the best way. There is also, I think, one less severe level of alcohol dependence or abuse that I would call context-based dependence. And I think this particularly applies to our 20s. You might not have a problem with alcohol. You might be able to stop for weeks or months, maybe just weeks, let's say that, maybe a couple of days. But, you know, every time your friends say come out with us, let's go to the club. My God, I sound so old.
所以无论你在这个范围内处于什么位置，无论你认为“你永远是一个瘾君子”这种说法是否应该存在，它在很大程度上都是个人的选择，什么能够让你以最好的方式度过依赖和成瘾。我认为还有一个不太严重的酒精依赖或滥用水平，我称之为基于环境的依赖。我认为这尤其适用于我们的20多岁。你可能没有酒精问题。你可能能够戒酒几周或几个月，也许只是几周，我们这么说吧，也许几天。但是，每当你的朋友说出来和我们一起，去俱乐部吧。天哪，我听起来太老了。
Let's go clubbing. Let's go out. Let's go to this party. You have to drink. You feel like once you're in that environment, there is no stopping you. That is not just addiction in the traditional sense, but rather a contextual reliance on alcohol kind of as a social lubricant or a way to fit in. Like you could not imagine going to something and not drinking.
我们去泡夜店吧。我们出去吧。我们去这个派对吧。你必须喝酒。你觉得一旦你处于那个环境中，就没有什么能阻止你了。这不仅仅是传统意义上的成瘾，而是对酒精的一种情境依赖，有点像社交润滑剂或融入其中的方式。就像你无法想象去参加什么活动而不喝酒一样。
and when you do it's incredibly hard. I think in these moments, drinking really does become tied to the context rather than a personal craving. Like this kind of dependence is subtle because when you're not in those environments, you might not want to drink at all. But it's also something that means,
而当你这样做的时候，实在是太难了。我认为在这些时刻，饮酒确实与情境挂钩，而不是个人渴望。这种依赖是微妙的，因为当你不在这些环境中时，你可能根本不想喝酒。但这也意味着，
you know, it's also a form of dependence that can go unnoticed. I think it's especially problematic when you're someone who gets to the party and can't stop drinking. So I think it's really worth, reflecting on whether the choice to drink in those moments is truly yours or if you're being influenced by the environment, by other people's expectations of you, and kind of just like this
你知道，这也是一种可能不被注意的依赖形式。我认为，当你是一个到了派对就停不下来喝酒的人时，这尤其成问题。所以我认为真的很值得反思，在那些时刻喝酒的选择是否真的是你自己的，还是你受到了环境的影响，受到了其他人对你的期望的影响，以及有点像这种
context-based reliance. You know, if you don't feel good after drinking and if you always like, God, I don't want to do that again, if you feel pressured, if you know you want to go for a run next day, but you still end up going too far, I think that that's when you know it's a bit of a dangerous social habit. Perhaps even for you, it's more linked to phoma, right? And the way alcohol reduces stress in a situation or makes it feel like you belong, you don't want to miss out on the fun. Perhaps it's a fear of social exclusion of not being part of the interesting stories, of not being part of the moment. But it is something that I think if you're in your 20s, you need to recognize how does drinking and social acceptance go hand in hand? Something really positive that I've
基于情境的依赖。你知道，如果你喝酒后感觉不好，如果你总是觉得，天哪，我再也不想那样做了，如果你感到有压力，如果你知道第二天想去跑步，但你最终还是做得太过分了，我认为这就是你知道这是一种有点危险的社交习惯的时候。也许对你来说，它更多地与错失恐惧症（FOMO）有关，对吧？以及酒精在特定情况下如何减轻压力或让你觉得有归属感，你不想错过乐趣。也许是对社交排斥的恐惧，害怕错过有趣的故事，害怕错过那一刻。但这是一件我认为如果你在20多岁时需要认识到的事情，饮酒和社交接受度是如何齐头并进的？我看到的
seen, you know, more and more, though, is a lot of us taking the sober route or being sober curious. That's the name for it these days. You know, there is this idea that you're either a problem drinker, an alcoholic, or a normal drinker. It was no issues with alcohol. But more and more, definitely seeing these like shades of grey when it comes to dependency. And sober curiosity is this amazing kind of lifestyle choice that doesn't require a complete, commitment to going sober for the rest of your life, but it does mean that you can choose to kind of dip your toes into occasional or periodic sobriety and just kind of modify your drinking habits without feeling like it's all or nothing. You know, it's not because you're necessarily worried
越来越多的一件非常积极的事情是，我们中的许多人走上了清醒的道路，或者对清醒感到好奇。这就是如今的名称。你知道，有一种观点认为，你要么是一个有问题的饮酒者、酒鬼，要么是一个正常的饮酒者。对酒精没有任何问题。但越来越多的人确实看到了这种关于依赖的灰度。而清醒好奇是一种了不起的生活方式选择，它不需要完全承诺在余生中保持清醒，但它确实意味着你可以选择偶尔或定期体验清醒，只是稍微改变你的饮酒习惯，而不会觉得一切非黑即白。你知道，这并不是因为你必然担心
about dependency. It's more that you've evaluated what drinking costs you versus what you would benefit from cutting down or going sober for small periods of time. I have noticed that more and more in my own social circles. Something I actually noticed recently was more non-alcoholic drinks being available at parties. It's become a lot more normal to ask someone like, are you drinking at the moment, rather than just assuming that they are, more people doing dry Jan or dry July. And I think that's really something we can expect more as we deprioritize drinking or make small swaps and you know I promise to tell you what I've known as the mental health thing has been one thing
关于依赖。更多的是你权衡了饮酒的代价与减少饮酒或短期保持清醒所带来的好处。我在自己的社交圈里越来越注意到这一点。我最近注意到的一件事是，派对上有了更多不含酒精的饮料。问别人“你现在在喝酒吗？”变得正常多了，而不是直接假设他们在喝酒，越来越多的人参加无酒精一月（Dry Jan）或无酒精七月（Dry July）。我认为随着我们不再把饮酒放在首位或做出微小的改变，我们可以期待更多这样的情况，而且我答应过告诉你们我所了解的，心理健康是一回事
but there are so many other benefits you sleep better you are less stress because you're not artificially elevating and then lowering and then elevating again your gabber and glutamate levels so your brain and body is able to find that sweet spot and stay there you know if you drink quite a bit and then you suddenly stop sometimes you do experience like a strange spike in anxiety in the first few weeks because your brain is adjusting to not having this substance to reduce or relax it, but after a while, like, it turns out that your body can manage that stress itself. It doesn't need the help of alcohol. We also see regeneration in the frontal lobe, which is where alcohol hits the hardest,
但还有很多其他好处，你睡得更好，你的压力更小，因为你没有人为地提高然后降低，接着又提高你的伽马氨基丁酸（GABA）和谷氨酸水平，所以你的大脑和身体能够找到那个最佳平衡点并保持在那里。如果你喝得比较多，然后突然停下来，有时在头几周你确实会经历一种奇怪的焦虑激增，因为你的大脑正在适应没有这种物质来减少或放松它，但过了一段时间，结果证明你的身体可以自己管理这种压力。它不需要酒精的帮助。我们还看到额叶的再生，这是酒精打击最严重的地方，
the frontal lobe and the cerebellum. And the frontal lobe is responsible for a lot of our executive functioning, decision-making, self-control, our emotions, our personality. and sometimes you might not know it, but prolonged and heavy drinking actually kills off brain cells in that area and across the brain, and it causes your brain to shrink. It reduces brain volume. So that is why alcohol is so often implicated in neurological diseases like Alzheimer's and Parkinson's.
额叶和小脑。额叶负责我们的许多执行功能、决策、自我控制、情绪和个性。有时你可能不知道，长期大量饮酒实际上会杀死该区域以及整个大脑的脑细胞，并导致大脑萎缩。它减小了脑容量。这就是为什么酒精经常与阿尔茨海默病和帕金森病等神经系统疾病有关。
When you are young and you cut back, you're giving your brain more of a chance. And you're allowing your brain space to prune, rewire, keep those cells healthy and that's why you may see an increase in mental clarity oh my goodness if I have not noticed that I have less brain fog almost none at the moment you feel refreshed you can get more done also you know because your sleep is likely improved as well like this is all coming together it's a common myth that you know alcohol helps you sleep it's where the term nightcap came from like having a drink, a cap of something to help you fall asleep.
当你年轻并且减少饮酒时，你正在给你的大脑更多机会。你正在留出空间让大脑修剪、重新连线，保持这些细胞健康，这就是为什么你可能会看到精神清晰度有所提高，哦，天哪，如果我没有注意到我的脑雾减少了，目前几乎没有。你感到神清气爽，你可以完成更多的工作。而且，你知道，因为你的睡眠可能也得到了改善，所以这一切都在融合在一起。这是一个普遍的神话，你知道酒精能帮助你睡眠，这就是“睡前酒”（nightcap）这个词的由来，就像喝一杯酒，一小杯东西来帮助你入睡。
Actually, to myth bust that one for you, drinking worsens your sleep quality significantly because it makes it harder for you to enter and therefore stay in REM sleep. So not drinking, better shut I. One of the things I've also noticed that I didn't expect was how much inflammation went away in my face particularly, but also in my body. Like within a week, I wasn't as puffy. I got less headaches. My skin was breaking out less.
实际上，为了打破这个神话，饮酒会显著恶化你的睡眠质量，因为它使你更难进入并因此保持在快速眼动（REM）睡眠状态。所以不喝酒，睡眠更好。我注意到的另一件意想不到的事情是，我脸上的炎症减少了多少，特别是在身体上也是如此。在一周内，我就没有那么浮肿了。头痛减少了。皮肤爆发减少了。
It looked healthier. And that was just me going from like mid-range social drinking to no drinking at all. And it still made a really big difference. Like, oh my goodness. Even my hands and like my face is the big one where I just feel less like bloated and less like puffy. And it's really hard to like see, I think. if you as someone, like just a friend or a stranger and you weren't seeing my face every day, but obviously as someone who sees it every day, like I've definitely noticed this decline.
它看起来更健康。这只是我从中间档次的社交饮酒过渡到完全不喝酒。它仍然产生了很大的不同。就像，哦，天哪。甚至我的手和脸也是最大的变化，我只是觉得不那么臃肿，不那么浮肿了。而且我认为很难看出来，如果你作为一个陌生人或朋友，并没有每天看到我的脸，但显然作为每天都能看到它的人，我绝对注意到了这种消退。
Your liver, your heart, they both do better. And this raises a really important point I haven't spoken about yet, which is another myth, the myth that alcohol is actually good for our health. I listened to this fascinating podcast by The New York Times called How Bad Is Alcohol for You Really, in which they basically debunk this idea that alcohol has any health benefit. Most of us have probably heard this suggestion or this quote unquote fact that a glass of red wine is like, good for your heart, it has antioxidants. Like it was even a fact that was like in the episode, like in an episode of the office,
你的肝脏、你的心脏，它们都表现得更好。这就提出了一个我还没谈到的非常重要的点，这是另一个神话，即酒精实际上对我们的健康有益的迷思。我听了《纽约时报》一个名为《酒精对你到底有多大危害》（How Bad Is Alcohol for You Really）的精彩播客，他们在其中基本上揭穿了酒精对健康有任何益处的观点。我们大多数人都可能听说过这种说法或所谓的“事实”，即一杯红酒对心脏有益，它含有抗氧化剂。甚至连《办公室》（The Office）的一集里都有这个“事实”，
it's so commonly spread. But actually when you review the study that this fact is taken from, the way they interpreted their data was really misleading. and now so many people believe a false conclusion. When they conducted this original study, they basically looked at people who drank versus didn't drink. And, you know, the people who did drink, it was quite moderate, maybe a couple of glasses of wine.
它传播得如此广泛。但实际上，当你回顾得出这个事实的研究时，他们解释数据的方式具有极大的误导性。现在有这么多人相信了一个错误的结论。当他们进行这项最初的研究时，他们基本上观察了饮酒者与不饮酒者。而且，你知道，那些喝酒的人是相当适度的，也许几杯酒。
And what they found was that those who drank moderately were healthier than those who didn't drink at all. And it was this huge finding at the time. But what they didn't control for, and anyone studying psychology knows you need to control for your confess. sounding extraneous variables. They didn't control for the people who were in that sober group who had stopped drinking because they had a real problem
他们发现适度饮酒者比完全不饮酒者更健康。这在当时是一个巨大的发现。但他们没有控制的是，任何学心理学的人都知道你需要控制你的混杂因素和外来变量。他们没有控制那些处于清醒组中因为有真正的问题而停止饮酒的人
and it had begun to impact their health. Now, it's kind of hard these days to find someone who is completely sober. And one of the reasons that someone might be completely sober is because they can't drink. So all of those people who were included in the no drinking group, it wasn't like they'd never drunk before in their life. it was actually the opposite. They had a problem. And so they were basically pulling down the group average of non-drinkers compared to casual
并且这已经开始影响他们的健康。现在，这些天很难找到一个完全清醒的人。而某人可能完全清醒的原因之一可能是因为他们不能喝酒。所以所有被纳的不喝酒组中的那些人，并不是他们一生中从未喝过酒。实际上恰恰相反。他们有问题。所以他们基本上拉低了非饮酒者相对于偶饮者的群体平均水平
drinkers so it looked like the casual drinkers were healthier. That is a classic example in psychology research of poor sampling methods, not controlling for your extraneous or confounding variables. And knowing that now, you know, there's been so many more studies coming out saying, actually, this is not good for your heart, this is not good for your liver, this causes cancer. there are entire countries that have changed their dietary recommendations when it comes to alcohol saying it is not safe for you to drink at all. It will increase your likelihood of dying. Maybe you only buy a tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny bit, but still.
饮酒者，所以看起来好像适度饮酒的人更健康。这是心理学研究中一个经典的例子，说明采样方法不好，没有控制好外部或混杂变量。现在知道了这一点，你知道的，有越来越多的研究出来说，实际上，这对你的心脏不好，这对你的肝脏不好，这会导致癌症。有些国家甚至改变了关于酒精的膳食建议，说你根本不安全。这会增加你死亡的可能性。也许你只买了一点点、一点点、一点点，但依然如此。
Actually, interestingly, as I'm recording this, it actually looks like the US will be the next country to make a recommendation that people shouldn't drink. Obviously, it's a very harsh recommendation, but they want to do what's safe. all of this sounds very very scary but something to note that i found really fascinating even the man who discovered the problem in those findings who said you know to everyone for years alcohol isn't safe we shouldn't tell people that he actually get this he still drinks and he is very open about the fact that he loves a couple glasses of wine and i think that is the important thing moderation is important and it reminds me of that quote which basically says like you know yes sun gives you cancer ice cream is bad for you spending your money ruins your savings
事实上，有趣的是，在我录制这段内容时，美国似乎将成为下一个建议人们不要喝酒的国家。显然，这是一个非常严厉的建议，但他们希望确保安全。所有这一切听起来非常非常可怕，但有一点需要注意，我觉得非常迷人，甚至连那些发现这些研究结果有问题的人——他曾经多年对每个人说酒精不安全，我们不应该这样告诉人们——实际上，你听好了，他自己还在喝酒，并且非常坦率地承认他喜欢几杯葡萄酒，我认为这才是重要的事情，适度很重要，这让我想起了那句名言，大意是，是的，太阳会给你带来癌症，冰淇淋对你不利，花钱会毁了你的储蓄。
wine isn't the healthiest it ruins your liver but i'm going to do it anyway i want to have fun it's a good good philosophy to have but yes anything can kill you everything can be bad for you how terrible is that but actually it's not because life is actually about sometimes indulging and having fun and enjoying flavor and enjoying richness. And I think that if you don't have a serious problem with alcohol abuse, maybe, and definitely why not enjoy what you enjoy, enjoy the feeling, the sensation, the friendships that you might feel like you get from a glass of wine or a little apparel sprits every now and again. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we come back, I want to talk about how sobriety
葡萄酒并不是最健康的，它会毁了你的肝脏，但我不管怎样都要喝，我想玩得开心，这是一个很好的哲学，但是是的，任何东西都能杀死你，每样东西都对你不利，这有多糟糕？但实际上并非如此，因为生活其实有时在于纵情享受、寻欢作乐、品味风味和享受丰富。我认为，如果你没有严重酗酒的问题，也许，为什么不享受你所享受的，享受这种感觉、感官、偶尔一杯葡萄酒或一杯开胃酒带来的友谊。好的，我们要休息一下，但当我们回来时，我想谈谈戒酒如何
impacted my social life, what it was like to go out sober, and just like some fast, rapid fire tips I have if you want to give it a go. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates.
影响了我的社交生活，清醒着出门是什么感觉，以及如果你想尝试一下的话，我有一些快速、连珠炮式的建议。2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导该行业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
健康产业。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上是会引起炎症的。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍了小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的可卡因。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为国会。可卡因。我随时准备在节目中谈论可卡因，只是为了让你们所有人知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你补充完这句话。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《难得糊涂》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、有时当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯、
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《难得糊涂》中就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct?
打开你的免费IHeartRadio应用，搜索《难得糊涂》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战的序幕，以证明真相。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的杀毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天呐。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义伸张之前，这一切都不会结束
is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think a big fear we have around trying dry Jen, dry July, whatever it is, going sober for a couple of months is social exclusion. Am I going to be included? Are people going to think that I'm like a wet blanket, that I'm not fun? Am I going to be left out?
在亚利桑那州。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。我认为我们对尝试戒酒一个月、干爽七月、无论是什么、戒酒几个月的一个巨大恐惧是社交排斥。我会不会被融入？人们会不会觉得我是个扫兴的人，我不好玩？我会不会被冷落？
Is it going to be less enjoyable to be the only sober one? that was definitely a fear that I had in like just doing 30 days of this especially like it's summer in Australia like everyone wants to do little arvo beverages so like it definitely felt like I was going to be missing out but something that I've really noticed is that my friends are very very accepting now if you have a friend group that is pressuring you to drink I don't think those people are your friends they're not your friends because if they only feel like they can enjoy your company
做唯一一个清醒的人是不是没那么愉快？这绝对是我在做这30天时所担心的，特别是这在澳大利亚是夏天——每个人都想喝点下午酒，所以这绝对让我觉得我会错过什么。但我真正注意到的是，我的朋友们现在非常非常接受。如果你有一个朋友圈向你施压让你喝酒，我认为这些人不是你的朋友，他们不是你的朋友，因为如果他们觉得只有在你可以
a glass or something, you know, a can of something in their hand, like, that's not authentic. Like, I don't know. I just feel like your relationships shouldn't be elevated by drinking. They should be just as good when you're sober as they are, when you're tipsy as they are when you're drunk. And I went out sober the other night. Like, it was a friend's birthday party, like a really good friend. And I went out and I was like, okay, I'm committing to this. I'm committing to this. I'm going to drive.
手里拿著一杯或某种东西的时候，你知道的，某种罐装饮料，才能享受你的陪伴，那是不真实的。就像，我不知道。我只是觉得你们的关系不应该靠喝酒来升华。当你们清醒时，关系应该和微醺时一样好，和喝醉时一样好。前几天晚上我清醒着出门了。就像，这是一个朋友的生日派对，一个非常好的朋友。我出门了，我想，好吧，我致力于此。我致力于此。我要开车。
I'm going to drive me and my boyfriend. we're going to meet like 30 of our friends and I'm going to like just chill on the diet coax for a little while the first hour this is what I learned the first hour was the worst just get that out of the way first hour was the worst because everyone was kind of like getting into the vibe everyone was kind of having a few drinks like lightening up and it was very much like based around like let's go to the bar like this drink tastes good we're going to sit and sit so I was a bit like I just feel like I'm missing out you guys are all like getting more cheerful more cheerful and I'm just feeling like I'm left out here of my own of course with my own actions but then after the first hour was done it was so much fun it was so much fun because I was more fun because I was more present because I wasn't sleepy because I didn't just sit in a corner and just chat to one person I was more like aware of who I wanted to speak to what I wanted to get out of the night I was able to like I know this sounds weird, but actually have some foresight to like organize things, do things.
我要开车载我和我男朋友。我们要去见大约30个朋友，我打算在无糖可乐上放松一会儿。第一个小时，这是我学到的，第一个小时是最糟糕的。先把这个抛开，第一个小时是最糟糕的，因为每个人都有点像进入状态，每个人都有点像喝了几杯，开始放松，这非常像是围绕着“我们去酒吧吧，这个饮料尝起来不错，我们坐下来”这种氛围。所以我有点像，我只是觉得我错过了什么，你们都在变得越来越高兴，越来越高兴，而我在这里感觉被冷落了，当然这是我自己的行为造成的。但第一个小时过后，太有趣了，太有趣了，因为我更有趣，因为我更投入，因为我没有犯困，因为我没有只坐在角落里跟一个人聊天，我更清楚我想和谁说话，我想从这个夜晚得到什么。我能够像，我知道这听起来很奇怪，但实际上有一些远见来组织事情，做事情。
Like there was karaoke in the back of this bar. And I was like, okay, like, I'll take the initiative and I'll book this because everyone else has kind of like had a few drinks and is probably not thinking about whether that's possible. Also really, really fun was driving everyone home afterwards. Let me tell you this. I had more fun being the designated driver and getting to drop all of my drunk friends home than I have ever had in a club. and I know that is a huge statement, but it is a correct one. It is an accurate one. I could not tell you the last time I went clubbing and had a good time.
就像这个酒吧后面有卡拉OK。我想，好吧，我会采取主动，我会预订这个，因为其他人可能已经喝了几杯，可能没有考虑这是否可能。同样非常非常有趣的是事后开车送每个人回家。让我告诉你这个。作为指定司机，把所有喝醉的朋友送回家，我获得的乐趣比我在俱乐部里获得的任何乐趣都要多。我知道这是一个巨大的声明，但这是一个正确的声明。这是一个准确的声明。我简直说不出我上一次去夜店玩得开心是什么时候。
Like, it's just not something that I think I like to do. Obviously, when I was, I actually probably could tell you, like, when I was in my early 20s and, like, in my teen years, it was, like, a great time. It was part of, like, socializing at uni, but since I've kind of hit my mid-20s, like, it's just not my thing anymore. And I would always try and force myself to really enjoy it and get something out of it and make memories. That's the big reason why I would go was for the memories.
就像，这根本不是我认为我喜欢做的事情。显然，当我，我其实大概可以说出来，比如当我二十岁出头和十几岁的时候，那真是一段美好的时光。那是大学社交的一部分，但自从我二十五岁左右以来，这就根本不是我的菜了。我总是试图强迫自己真正享受它，从中获得一些东西并留下回忆。这就是我去的最大原因，为了回忆。
I made more fun memories driving my friends home and going to McDonald's. And they said the funniest stuff and it was like, I can remember the injokes. I can remember what they were saying, like the stories that were told. And then the next morning, I was up by 8 a.m. It was still a Sunday. I still had my sleep in. But I was up by 8 a.m. I was refreshed.
送朋友回家和去麦当劳让我留下了更多有趣的回忆。他们说了最搞笑的话，就像，我能记住内部的笑话。我能记住他们在说什么，比如那些讲过的故事。然后第二天早上，我8点就起床了。那仍然是一个星期天。我仍然睡了个懒觉。但我8点就起床了。我很精神。
I felt amazing. I went for a 5K. run and I just thought wow like I would not have this energy if I had had four gin and tonics last night and I would have missed out on so much and I also didn't get tired so I was able to stay out longer which is a big problem I sometimes have when I drink and go out like I have two red wines and I'm like I want to go to bed but I really committed to it and it was a great time some tips I have for staying sober or trying out sobriety and I really would encourage you to just do 30 days.
我感觉棒极了。我去跑了5公里，我只是想，哇，如果我昨晚喝了四杯金汤力，我就不会有这种精力了，我会错过很多东西，而且我也没有感到疲劳，所以我能够待得更久，这是我有时喝酒出门时的一个大问题，我喝了两杯红酒，我就想去睡觉了，但我真的坚持了下来，这是一段美好的时光。我有一些关于保持清醒或尝试戒酒的建议，我真的鼓励你只做30天。
Have like a non-alcoholic drink that you like. So kombucha, diet Coke, lemonade, non-alcoholic beer. A big fan of non-alcoholic beer. Not so much non-alcoholic red wine. That stuff is disgusting. Have your drink that you enjoy that you can bring to the party. You can order at the pub. You can order at the bar.
喝一种你喜欢的无酒精饮料。比如康普茶、健怡可乐、柠檬水、无酒精啤酒。我很喜欢无酒精啤酒。不太喜欢无酒精红酒。那种东西太恶心了。喝你喜欢的饮料，你可以带到派对上。你可以在酒吧点。你可以在酒吧点。
Like that really helps you feel like you're still integrated into the experience. Tell your friends that you are sober and like open up a discussion about it. so it's not like expected that you're going to be drinking and they can actually think through their own drinking choices and you can change plans based on your choice for the evening. See if someone wants to do it with you. Honestly, like one of my friends is doing it at the same time. It's like kind of fun to exchange stories and just kind of have a bigger goal attached to why you want to do it. So if you're just like, I want to go sober for 30 days but you don't know why, it's going to be a lot harder to achieve.
这真的能帮助你觉得你仍然融入了整个体验中。告诉你的朋友你是清醒的，并围绕它展开讨论。这样大家就不会期望你会喝酒，他们可以真正思考他们自己的饮酒选择，你可以根据你对当晚的选择来改变计划。看看是否有人想和你一起做。老实说，我的一位朋友也在同时做这件事。交换故事感觉挺有趣的，而且围绕着你为什么要这样做有一个更大的目标。所以如果你只是说，我想戒酒30天，但你不知道为什么，实现起来就会困难得多。
So mine was really like this is a personal challenge. I want to see if I'm capable. For other people, it's like they're training for a marathon. They're training for a big run. Maybe it's that you want to see your skin improve. Whatever it is, make sure that the reason you're doing this is really, really clear to you. And honestly, good luck. If you have done it before, please, or if you are someone who is currently sober and has been for a while,
所以我的真的很像这是一个个人挑战。我想看看我是否有能力。对其他人来说，就像他们在为马拉松做准备。他们在为长跑做准备。也许是你想看到你的皮肤改善。无论是什么，确保你这样做的原因对你来说是非常非常明确的。说真的，祝你好运。如果你以前做过，拜托，或者如果你目前是清醒的并且已经有一段时间了，
what can we expect in a couple of years? What can we expect in like six months, two years, five years? Like I've heard that it gets better and it changes and that you feel even more energy and more attuned to yourself after a while. And also send over your best tips and I'll share them on Instagram. But I think that's all we have for today's episode. I know it's been a long one. So if you've made it this far, hello.
我们可以在几年内期待什么？我们在大约六个月、两年、五年里可以期待什么？就像我听说情况会变好，会改变，一段时间后你会感到更多的精力和对自己的更多调谐。另外，把你们最好的建议发过来，我会在Instagram上分享它们。但我想这就是我们今天这一集的所有内容。我知道这期节目很长。所以如果你坚持到了这里，你好。
Comment a little wine emoji in the comments on Spotify. And I'll go through and see who's gotten here. But thank you so much for listening. Make sure that if you haven't already, you listen to Mantra. If you like the psychology of your 20s and you like the kind of positive calm environment we're creating here, you want some inspiration. Mantra is probably going to be exactly what you're looking for. So you can find it on Spotify, Apple Podcasts just by searching Mantra with Gemma Speg. Also, we are open to episode suggestions for this podcast at the moment.
在Spotify的评论区评论一个小小的高脚杯表情符号。我会去看一下谁听到了这里。非常感谢你们的收听。如果你还没听过，请确保收听Mantra。如果你喜欢20多岁的心理学，喜欢我们这里创造的这种积极平静的氛围，想要一些灵感。Mantra可能正是你一直在寻找的。你可以在Spotify、Apple Podcasts上搜索 Mantra with Gemma Speg 找到它。另外，我们目前接受这个播客的剧集建议。
If there is something about your 20s, you want me to explore the psychology behind, send it through. I would love to hear from you. Make sure you are following along. Make sure that you have left a five-star review, please, and thank you if you feel called to do so. And until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
如果你有关于20多岁的事情想让我探讨其背后的心理学，请发过来。我很乐意听到你的消息。请务必关注。如果你觉得有必要的话，请务必留下五星好评，谢谢。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己好一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed I will be his last target. He is not going to get away
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听数字“2”开头的播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓我会成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱的
with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
惩罚。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》播客。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived this. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
从1979年开始，这对我和来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每集节目中，我们都会邀请你来到这里，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何带着我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家一起度过这一切的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host's
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔在谈论80年代一样。之前这是一个疯狂的年份。这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast,
嘿，大家最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人主持的《吃一堑长一智》
or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。